left-hander eric lowery the first five
innings of his start
in denver was really good against
colorado last time out
and laura notches his first strike out
of the game best two-strike pitch in
baseball heater up
[Music]
that short arm action he gets it right
up above the hands hitters think i can
hit that umpire's gonna call it i got a
swing out of it it's too late
for chichi it'll be his 15th ball game
he's participated in it'll be start
number 11
for gonzalez and
backup slider i that's how i would
probably describe that but it gets a
strikeout on norvaez
two outs it is a slider and it's a bit
of a backup so it's
nobody knows how to throw that pitch
it's a mystery three and two
and he got him with a slider well done
great start
got tired a little bit the good thing
that he's on base a lot in that lead-off
spot
swings and missiles second strikeout for
eric lauer
using that high fastball with great
efficiency early on in this one
just kind of climbing the ladder go
another wrong up there prone when he
know he knows about halfway to the plate
if he's going to hit this ball or not
because you can just see it on his face
he's just like why am i swinging at that
fuentes center cut fastball and lauer
gets his third strikeout wasn't even
that much up i mean that's a very
hittable pitch it's almost like he had
his mind made up that hey
it's going to be inside if he throws a
cutter right there maybe he's all over
it but
that one stayed pretty true he knows he
probably should have hit it look at him
struck him out he ends up striking out
the side
it took 37 pitches to do it and the
rockies strand the bases loaded in the
second
strikes out trevor's story and it's a
one
two three inning five strikeouts
for eric lauer europe the hero
on friday sacrifice fly to win it try
and develop and get the confidence from
the coaching staff to go out there and
say hey
i'm gonna do this there's kesten here
with a blast to left
it's gone one-nothing
milwaukee on a rocket hit by
kesten hero hippo is torched
he took he had two really good takes in
that at-bat
i mean he is up on time with that front
foot aggressive
man that ball got out of here in a hurry
i think we're going to see a lot more of
this from kesley
flower notches a strikeout on another
high fastball
that's been working for him today you
look back the last time out against
these rockies
in colorado things are a little bit
different you feel a little bit off kind
of a wayward soldier in the sixth inning
he was good and for five i mean
he got his bad inning out of the way
luckily no run scored in the second but
since then he's just been relying on his
stuff
in the zone brewers have taken every
advantage against this rockies bullpen
just every facet they can whether it's
stolen bases
taking advantage of being hit by a pitch
3-2
swinging a fly ball right center back
warning track one in a b for narvaez
on the ninth pitch of the sequence he
goes yard
how many times has he done that this
year
long at that he wins with a productive
run scoring play
ninth pitch what a battle and you see
what he's trying to do just
flipping balls foul to the left side
waiting
just waiting for that mistake so many
pitches you're bound to make a mistake
down and in on a lefty that's a no-no
even
from a left-handed pitcher i think he
knew it right away
i think the only question is whether
he's going to hit that car in right
center or not
came up a little bit short homer and
strikeout for hiro today
looking to hit the ball hard against
lawrence
this one to right center casting hero
kept his hands inside and rips one off
the wall
two runs are going to score casting hero
with a two-run
double a beautiful piece of hitting from
the brewers first baseman
both of those runs right there scoring
both walks
peterson good speed on the base pass
that ball was scorched
had a little change up or something got
on the side of it just caught
way too much play casting hero heating
up
and just willing to let all the work let
the pitcher do all the work
coming in at that angle away from you
let it get deep
hunter strickland takes over for the
brewers he's been pretty good
at wearing a brewer's uniform so far
small sharply hit through the left side
and the rockies have just their third
knock of the game
so diaz has been on twice he had to walk
in the second
and he struck him out fastball in the
inner part of the play
tavia slams the bat down with pitch by
hunter strickland that's all narvaez
said that then he kind of knew the
fastball was coming
i mean it says four team fastball but it
almost looked like he had a little bit
of late cut
right before he tipped it into the glove
of narvaez
visually frustrating wave in a minutes
good slider by strickland
two away now first strikeout he's on
fastball
right here he just has so much better
feel throwing the slider against the
righty you have that reference point
strikes out gaza
after giving up a lead off single he
strikes out the side
trying to convert their eighth shutout
of the season
and it's ryan weber set to make his
second
big league appearance this year his
first as a member of the brewers he
becomes the 50th
player to appear in a game for the crew
this season
and trevor hits it on the ground and
there's no one over there it'll be an
infield hit
mirror got to it that was all so that's
the rocky's fourth hit
weber's not going to overpower you with
fastball it's a sinker
change of combination and for trevor
he's going to go inside out he sees that
here is the only one on the right side
so it's vacant he's got to punch it over
there it's exactly what he does he'll
take his knock
ryan mcmahon is going to pinch head over
seven in the series with six strikeouts
on one coming bouncer second base could
be two peterson
second one to first double play
you never get tired of watching the
pivot when william thomas is standing at
second base and he fires a dart to first
started with a changeup from weber down
in the zone
mcmahon trying to make something happen
right there
not what he wanted but i think we're
getting a good look at weber what he
does he gets the ball in the ground
brendan rodgers single back in the
second inning one of two hits allowed by
eric lauer
to first hear a diving stab gets up
throws to first in time
sweep complete of colorado five nothing
the final this
afternoon what a series by this brew
crew
ending on a high note right there the
hero of this game kesten here making a
great play at first base you got to feel
good
with the glove he's been doing it a lot
this year we saw it from the bat
today especially what a play
webber fielding his position that's
three ground balls that didn't get
into the outfield grass casting hero
went further than any ball
that weber gave up in this ninth inning